une grippe un inquiétant virus au 31
décembre 2019
impossible d'imaginer l'année qui
s'annonce tout commence mi décembre
un homme de 65 ans arrive à l'hôpital de
bourg ain capitale de la province
chinoise du roubaix ils présentent des
symptômes de fièvre et ses deux poumons
sont affectés quinze jours plus tard 260
cas similaires sont recensés un nouveau
virus est né l'épicentre de l'épidémie
est localisé au marché central de lujan
qui ferme ses portes dès le 1er janvier
dès le lendemain le génome du virus et
décoder le 6 janvier un plan d'urgence
et activé en chine
trois jours plus tard le virus obtient
un nom le sar skov 2 de la famille des
coronavirus le 23 janvier la ville de
l'oural et placé en quarantaine
ainsi qu'une large partie de la province
deux jours seulement avant la grande
fête du nouvel an chinois
mais plusieurs millions d'habitants ont
déjà quitté leur province pour rejoindre
leur famille
l'année du rat s'annonce de mauvaise
augure les résidents devraient coopérer
activement au travail de prévention et
de contrôle de notre communauté en
particulier les personnes ayant voyagé
ou résider à ouman au cours des deux
dernières semaines des 14 derniers jours
nous le recommandons en premier lieu de
se faire recenser le plus rapidement
possible dans la localité où le village
où ils se trouvent de réduire les
activités extérieures en particulier les
lieux très fréquentés les espaces
publics
début février des hôpitaux de campagne
sont construits en une dizaine de jours
pour accueillir les quelques 1000
patients de la région
dans le même temps le pangolin est
pointé du doigt par les chercheurs
chinois qui identifie des similitudes
avec la composition du virus la chine
commence à organiser des dépistage
massif pour isoler les malades et briser
les chaînes de contamination une
stratégie qui paie deux mois plus tard
le nombre des contaminations baisse de
façon spectaculaire la région sort alors
doucement de son confinement symbole
important le chef de l'état se rend dans
les rues de bourg ain
communauté ont fait un excellent travail
dans notre guerre défensive notre guerre
de résistance au nom du comité central
du parti
je vous exprime mes sincères
condoléances et mes sincères
remerciements
mais au même moment l'épidémie de kobe
19 est déclarée pandémie par l'om est ce
le virus circule à une vitesse
grandissante à travers le monde tandis
que certains dirigeants restent
sceptiques
la chine met en garde cette maladie
infectieuse pourrait tuer plus de gens
que les deux guerres mondiales a réuni
elle est très dangereuse
vu la situation il est extrêmement
imprudent de la part de diverses forces
politiques de ne considérer que leurs
propres besoins politiques et d'ignorer
la vie des gens ordinaires
pendant ce temps la course au vaccin
commence à faire rage
les pays luttent pour trouver une
solution face au virus
tandis que nombreux sont les pays qui
entame des mesures de confinement
le coc vite 19 a alors tué plus de 315
mille personnes dans le monde la chine
où désormais aucun nouveau cas n'est
recensée dans la capitale pékin la vie
elle reprend doucement son cours
je suis resté dans ma ville d'origine et
je ne pouvais pas sortir maintenant
l'épidémie se calme alors je peux sortir
et travailler hors de chine le virus
continue de se répandre à grande vitesse
bouleversant les agendas politiques
mettant au défi les systèmes de santé
avec ses répercussions douloureuses dans
les domaines sanitaires économiques et
sociaux une année noire qui s'achève
pour beaucoup sans regret les yeux
désormais rivés sur 2021